what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and today i was so fortunate enough to
attend the black
widow press conference over zoom of
course not in person yet
i can't wait till they start doing them
in person again but it was awesome to
see
scarlett johansson florence pugh david
harbor rachel vice kate shortland and
kevin feige talk about black widow since
we've been waiting for it for such
a long time and the cast really is great
together on
and off screen in the film you can tell
that the cast has a lot of chemistry
with each other which makes for a really
good film so there is a lot to go over
from this press conference and i think
if you are very excited for black widow
you'll enjoy
what the cast had to say i am going to
kind of go out of order of the questions
that were asked during the press
conference because i want to talk about
david harbour specifically because to me
he's kind of the comedy of the film his
character
red guardian is a really good character
and for those of you who may not be
aware i did get to pre-screen black
widow a couple of days ago so i have
seen the film
so sarah spain from espn was the host
and commentator
for this press conference and she asked
david harbour how he establishes the
line between
seriousness and humor and comedy and his
reply was fantastic he
said what's really funny about it is
that it hatches from
the same egg the pathos and also the
humor of this character
he is filled with grief over the choices
that he's made like emotionally
spiritually and nutritiously because
obviously he's not in that good of shape
anymore
but he continues to say that the comedy
itself comes out of the ego
that is built to defend the remorse
that's inherently silly that's
inherently funny so in other words he
says he has to be bombastic because he
can't stop
and feel these things you know all of
his failures so he builds around him
kind of a psychotic world where he
is the hero and that's where he says
that's inherently silly and
inherently funny then he goes on to say
also the family dynamics themselves
are just so fun there's almost a
traditional shot of
us all around a table where we're all in
super suits i found us all falling into
this cliche rolls and then
riffing off them that was really fun and
satisfying as well
and it really is you know you have these
super people you have three black widows
three highly trained assassins and the
red guardian who
is a super soldier you know the russian
captain america and we've all seen this
part in the trailers they
all just kind of sit down and have like
a family moment and it is kind of
inherently funny but it's also a great
emotional scene that adds to the dynamic
of what we're watching as the press
conference continued scarlett johansson
was asked
how she felt to welcome new people to
the marvel family
through the black widow cast in which
she replied it's exciting because i'm
partial
i love our marvel family and i know how
special it is and how special
experiences are making these films so
i'm just excited for other actors to
come in because i know
i hope they all feel similarly it's
wonderful to see people come into things
excited and wide eyes and get to
experience the incredible world of
marvel
and making these huge productions we
have all been a part of big productions
before
but i think because marvel feels so
familial it's just a unique
warm inviting place it's just a fun
thing to share and that says a lot about
marvel and disney you know
huge huge companies huge productions but
at the heart of it all
it's still very warm and welcoming and
calm and i personally think that's why
they can make such good films
just comfortability on the set and in
the writer's room
now i know a lot of people have
personally asked me about the fight
scenes of the film and i do think that
they are really great
i like the hand-to-hand combat that we
see there's one-on-one fights there's
big chase scenes there's group fights
and director kate shortland was asked
that while crafting these fight scenes
if she looked at previous mcu films for
influence on the style
and what she said was different fights
had different hearts to them
say we're looking at the fight on the
bridge with taskmaster she's trying to
use her skill set but the character
she's fighting
he can do what she can do basically
scarlett can't use those skills
what we tried to do in other fights was
to really mess it up
and it became like a street fight with
her sister she's up against a formidable
opponent so those fights became messy
and raw and that was really fun
and i can attest to that those fights
that get messy they are really fun and
they're really awesome to watch
i personally think that the fights to me
were the coolest parts of the film
even between natasha and elena that was
one of the best fights of the film and
i'm glad they put a lot of effort
into understanding what the fight
actually is and i'm glad these fights
did become messy
now a really fun question that was asked
to david harbor and rachel weiss was
which other marvel hero would you like
your character to team up with
david harbour after sarcastically
stating that nobody is on red guardian's
level said that he would love to team up
with anthony mackie's captain america
as we know the red guardian is
essentially the russian captain america
and in the film we learn how he feels
about steve rogers's captain america and
i think a movie
with anthony mackey's captain america
and david harbor's red guardian would be
absolutely hilarious and awesome to
watch i also would really really love
a red guardian solo movie which they
briefly mentioned but didn't really talk
about
david made a joke like kevin are you
listening i don't think there's any
serious talks about this
at marvel studios right now but i for
sure would love to see a red guardian
film
there's a lot of story to tell there in
fact david harper says you have this big
25 year gap that we don't know we don't
know what happened in red guardian's
life
he has all these stories about his life
and what went on they are questionable
about what's real i do think the classic
cold war thing
is a really fun and funny dynamic
between these two guys and the fact that
they basically came up as nuclear
warheads in an arms race together so
again i would love to see that and then
rachel vice said
the hulk which after you see the movie
you can see why this would be a pretty
interesting choice and no i am not
stating that the hulk or bruce banner is
in the movie
they are not now here's a very
interesting question that i think fans
would like to know
kevin feige was asked if we should
expect more prequels and here's what he
said
this film and this story is a particular
case for natasha
but the notion of exploring the past
present and future
of the mcu is certainly in the cards for
all of our characters
which is absolutely fantastic news for
the heroes that don't get their own solo
films and we don't really see the entire
origin story play out
it would be really really cool to see
prequels even for
yelena bulova herself it would be nice
to see a lot more of her experience
in the red room as a black widow the
fact that prequels are on the table for
kevin feige says that there's a lot of
potential for the mcu
then scarlett johansson was asked how
did the story for black widow come about
and i was actually a little bit
surprised with her answer as to when
they decided to do a black widow film
she stated we started talking about this
film as more of a serious possibility
when we were doing
infinity war we already knew what the
end game was for natasha
we wanted to make sure that was a choice
she made actively that it felt like she
had resolved then
so knowing that we had to work backwards
so she could get to a place where that
was possible
we knew that in this film she had to
evolve to a place where she was moving
forward in her life
and had resolved the trauma from her
past that she felt like a different
person
moving forward if that makes sense it
was a very weird way of working
maybe that is always the case with a
prequel i've never done anything like
that
and that makes sense to me to me that's
a very interesting way to approach a
film you already know the characters
in game as she says we know that in
avengers in-game she's going to die so
in black widow
the story is about building up her
character to be
in a good enough place to where
everything about her past is already
taken care of and she feels comfortable
sacrificing herself and that's what
black widow is really about
clearing up those loose ends now i know
a lot of people
are wondering about yelena bulova and
she truly is a great character in this
film florence pew did an amazing job
playing her
and one of the questions that was asked
to florence p was how do you approach
yelena's connection to natasha and make
sure we understand it but
also make elena a character of her own
in what she said
from the get-go it was very obvious that
they have this connection and they have
this relationship and ultimately despite
her skill set
she is that wonderfully annoying younger
sister that says all the right things
at all the wrong times she would go on
to praise director kate shortland for
giving her the freedom to figure out
how elena thinks and how she moves what
she wears
florence says that i think for me that
was such a fun part of this character
she really comes out of the red room and
can start life and she can buy clothes
and she can buy the vest that has a lot
of pockets don't worry that will be
explained
in the movie and she says that she had
so much freedom to discover who elena
was that elena really does become
her own character and does flourish by
the end of the film and she also
complimented scarlett johansson for
being so
welcoming and for being so giving and
really making it a comfortable space
now a big final question that was asked
to scarlett was
what trait does scarlett johansson want
people to remember
about natasha romanov she initially
jokingly responds about her pose but
classic
black widow poses that we've seen her do
throughout the mcu
which the black widow film actually
addresses in a pretty hilarious way
but then on a more serious note she says
i think natasha has a lot of integrity
she's a big character she's not afraid
to admit when she's wrong
she's endearing that way she's curious
about herself and curious about other
people
i think it makes her stand out and it
definitely does
it's an incredible story arc black
widows if you think about it
she goes from being a russian spy and
assassinating people
to a character that has immense
integrity that would eventually go on to
sacrifice herself
to save the people she loves and the
world and it's really great in this
press conference that they really talked
about how much
effort and thought was put into this
movie because again we've waited for a
pretty long
time to get a solo black widow film and
i'm excited for everybody to watch it it
comes out publicly july
9th both on disney plus premiere access
and
in theaters be sure to let me know how
excited you are about the film in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you